e a birra que tu tem que aguentar que
quando tu era criança tu era o birren aí
agora tem o mais novo que
tu tu fica indignado fala mãe quando eu
era pequena era assim um
sagadinho é isso que acontece se tu é o
mais velho e se tu é o mais novo Tu é o
encosto da vida de outra pessoa só que
aí o jogo vira porque para onde ele vai
ele tem que te levar e o lugar que o
irmão mais velho vai é muito mais massa
do que o lugar que tu vai quando tu é
criança teu irmão te leva pra rodinha
dos amigos dele estão bebendo tu it
estão
bebendo as amigas do teu irmão mais
velha bonitono peitão fala ai é teu
irmão é é o mais novo eu eu sou mais
novo alguém Cuida de Mim Gente alguém
cuida de
mim